التصمم يتسلل الى اجساد الافغانيات معيدا
الى المشهد ما حدث في الجاره الايرانيه
طوال اشهر 80 تلميذه افغانيه تعرضنا الى
التسمم في حادثتين منفصلتين في مدرستين
ابتدائتين تقع المدرسه في منطقه سان الشرك
في ولايه
شمالي افغانستان وهما قريبتان من بعضهما
البعض مسؤول باداره التعليم اكد ان الشخص
الذي دبر عمليه التسمم كان لديه احقادا
شخصيه دون الخوض في تفاصيل هويته او اعمار
الفتيات اللواتي تسممنا يذكر انها المره
الاولى التي تشهد افغانستان هذا النوع من
الاعتداءات منذ وصول حركه طالبان الى
السلطه قبل عامين لكن حوادث مماثله اجتاحت
البلاد عام 2009 وتحديدا بالشمال عشرات
الطالبات نقلنا حينها للمستشفيات اثرى
استنشاقهن غازا غامضا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات